president trump says he would like to
get back on the campaign trail by
tomorrow just eight days after being
hospitalized
for the coronavirus and he's been
appearing in videos and doing phone
interviews where
he says he's doing just fine ben tracy
is at the white house for us ben good
morning to you
what's the president's doctor saying
good morning well the president's
physician dr sean connelly released this
brief
update last night in which he says that
the president is responding well to
treatment
and he but what this does not say is
whether or not the president is still
contagious or if he is tested negative
for the virus
and dr conley himself said president
trump would not be out of the woods
until monday
now he's saying the president might be
able to campaign saturday
yeah i just saw the doctors today they
think i'm in great shape
i'm in great shape in an interview
thursday night president trump claimed
again that he's feeling great
but his voice noticeably broke on two
occasions
on i think the first debate they
i will say this absentee is okay
because absentee ballots
excuse me the president says he's
getting ready to get back on the
campaign trail
despite cdc guidelines that recommend
getting two negative covers
isolation the president is shall we say
in an altar state right now the news
comes as house speaker nancy pelosi
plans to form a commission today
to review president trump's fitness for
office she's concerned about his
behavior
while taking the powerful steroid
dexamethasone
his disassociation from reality
would be funny if it weren't so deadly
president trump fired back
tweeting crazy nancy is the one who
should be under observation
i went into the hospital a week ago i
was very sick
and i took this medicine and it was
incredible
the president claims he's cured and
possibly immune
even though there is no cure an immunity
is still being studied
my understanding is that it's his
private medical history
the white house is still refusing to say
when the president last tested negative
for kovit
which would help determine how long he's
been infected and who he may have
exposed to the virus
there are now 25 people associated with
president trump or events here at the
white house who have now tested positive
for the virus republican senate majority
leader mitch mcconnell says
he's not been here to the white house in
two months because he doesn't think
they're taking the right precautions
gail all right ben thank you